JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
I think we're good to go,
so we'll get started.
Thank you very much for coming
to this session.
I know there's a lot of other
options that are exciting and
interesting, but I think this
is going to be fun.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
I work for YouTube.
And today we would like to talk
about the challenges and
opportunities related to mobile
video game play uploads
from your game.
Today we'll have a couple
of speakers.
Daniel Hermes, a colleague of
mine from Google, Kenji Arai
from YouTube Biz Dev.
He has made this talk possible
by amazing sponsorship and
pulling strings.
We have Jens Owen from LunarG.
They build a pretty interesting
cloud-based
rendering technology we
wanted to show you.
We will have Wayne Karo
from Free Range Games.
They make beautiful
mobile games, and
he's an awesome gamer.
And he will have a chance to
show off his skills right
here, live on stage,
in five minutes.
You ready?
All right.
And Amir Ebrahimi, who
is a Unity 3D guru.
I would like to acknowledge
Unity.
They have really helped us put
this presentation together and
allowed us to access their
source code license which was
required for some of the
approaches that we'll be
describing.
And last, but not least, we
have Coby Cotton from Dude
Perfect who just flew in this
morning from Austin, Texas,
where I hear it's quite
warm today.
All right, so agenda
for today.
We'll talk about why
this is important.
Why we are here and why YouTube
cares, and why you
should care.
We'll talk about YouTube APIs
and various approaches in
which you can enable video
uploads from your title.
And then I'll give
you a couple of
demos of awesome games.
So let's get into it
So first of all, let's just kind
of look at the industry,
what's happening.
And I'm using some stats
from Digi-Capital.
They have allowed us to share
this with you today.
So really what's happening to
the market, as you all know,
it's kind of segmenting into two
areas-- value games, which
is the traditional [INAUDIBLE]
titles, console games, and
volume games.
And you see a lot of the volume
gaming picking up in
emerging markets.
Also, markets such as Japan
and Korea are doing well.
And these are social games,
mobile games.
That market is actually
growing very fast.
So as you see, the numbers,
it's actually
a 14% growth rate.
Most of that is actually
happening in Asia and Europe.
So this is what's happening in
the mobile gaming space.
And we like that.
If you look at the United
States actually, the
projection is by 2014,
we'll have 141
million mobile gamers.
So almost half of the country
will be playing mobile games,
which is quite amazing.
Now, what do gamers
like to do?
Well, they like watching
videos.
And when you ask them what type
of videos they like to
watch, obviously they
like trailers.
But then the second most popular
category is the actual
user game play.
So this is authentic
user-generated content that
they like to watch.
And I'm one of them.
I am quite addicted to watching
game play videos.
They are fun.
But what's even more fun is
creating them, and this is
what we'll talk about today.
Which brings us to YouTube.
Couple of questions
about YouTube.
So I want to throw some numbers
at you and see if you
can recognize what these
numbers mean.
So first number is
200 million.
Any guesses what this
number represents?
Hint-- it's related to mobile.
No guesses?
[AUDIENCE]
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Ah, somewhat.
So this is how many mobile
YouTube views we had in 2010.
I know, that was a difficult
question.
So here's an easier question,
600 million?
[AUDIENCE]
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Ah, yes.
You win the T-shirt.
Please come find me after the
talk, and we'll try to hook
you up with one.
So this is how many YouTube
mobile views we get in 2012.
So the number has tripled.
Finally, 800 million?
Any guesses?
One observant engineer colleague
of mine noticed that
it's actually the sum
of 200 and 600.
And it is the correct answer.
But this is how many users
we have worldwide.
So this is just to kind of give
you an idea of what's
happening in the mobile
space and
generally in the user space.
So one thing about the users
that we found is that people
that play video games, they like
watching YouTube videos.
And if you ask them what they do
after they watch the video,
a fair amount of them actually
goes and buys one.
They buy the game.
And this is the traditional
gaming market.
And then a lot of them also
search for more information.
So this content that is out
there-- and remember, trailers
as well as user-generated
content generates user
activities.
So the people that are
interested in gaming, they'll
actually go and find
more information
thanks to that content.
So one example of a game that
has very successfully
integrated this functionality
is Talking Tom.
Anybody with kids
in the audience?
Quite a few people.
You guys have that
on your phones?
If you don't, you will
probably soon.
So what they have done is they
integrated YouTube video
uploads into their game.
And it is basically
a virtual pet.
You can talk to the cat.
It talks back to you.
You can pet it and so forth.
They have 400 million
uploads--
sorry, downloads to date.
So it's a huge, huge success--
100 million active users, over
750,000 videos uploaded by
their users.
And that content has generated
345 million views.
And just to put it in
perspective, this is actually
a very significant
number of views.
So this is in the same category
as a lot of the
YouTube stars are getting or
some of the popular viral
videos are getting.
So this is really an incredible
number, all through
user--generated content.
And what they've been able
to do is really to enable
self-expression with their
application, their little
game, and the rest is history.
Now, if you don't do anything,
if you don't want to take
advantage of the trends that
we're seeing, you'll miss out
on a couple of things.
We find our users that watch
these game play videos are
very engaged.
It actually creates great
community and all that other
good stuff-- promotion,
analytics--
that come with having
all that content.
And you can also make a little
money on this through
monetization, which will offset
your development costs.
So next question is, now that we
look at the market and all
the trends are heading in the
positive direction, we have
these huge user populations,
well, really, how hard is it?
People have done this on
consoles, on PC games, through
multiple approaches.
But we don't see that much of
that in the mobile space.
And obviously at YouTube, we
would like that because we
feel it's good for the users.
It's good for the industry,
and it's good for us.
So, this brings us
to YouTube APIs.
Quick question, who in
the audience has
used YouTube APIs?
Fair amount of people.
It's a nice community.
For those of you that haven't,
we have data
APIs and player APIs.
Data APIs allow you to basically
integrate with our
back end and do most of the
things you can do on
youtube.com, including video
uploads programmatically
directly from your game.
Player APIs allow you to
incorporate YouTube video
playback in your application.
So whether it's a console--
sorry, it's a web-based
game, a mobile
game, you can do that.
And data APIs are
based on REST.
If you've worked with any other
Google APIs, really they
are very easy to use.
Player APIs, we have JavaScript
ActionScript.
And we also have a
new thing coming.
We will be previewing it at
Google I/O, which is a YouTube
Android player API, which
allows you to integrate
YouTube video playback directly
into your Android
application using
Java-based API.
There's a session about this
tomorrow afternoon.
I'm encouraging you to see
that if you would like to
incorporate the video playback
into your title as well.
So there's actually a couple of
approaches to incorporating
YouTube video uploads
into your game.
And the way I look at it is,
I see three different
approaches--
the proven, relatively easy,
reliable approach; the one
that is very promising but
kind of out there, more
futuristic; and one that is
really a mix of the two.
And to visualize it, I think
this is a good analogy.
So we have a Volkswagen
Jetta--
good solid engineering, not
super expensive, does the job
really well.
It's here today.
And we have the Beamer.
It's a wonderful car, but I
don't think you can buy that
one in the stores just yet.
It has a lot of potential.
I would like to have one.
And then we have the
Prius wagon.
I mean, it's definitely
here today.
It'll offer some of the
advantages of the previous
two, not as expensive
as the middle.
So this is really what we're
going to talk about today, is
how do we incorporate video
uploads into a game using your
device's resources within the
limitations of your device?
Then how can you leverage the
cloud to actually offload some
of the processing for you?
And then finally, can you come
up with a balance between the
two to kind of have a
mix of both works?
So now we'll talk about
local video capture.
And we will use a game from
Dude Perfect that
was recently launched.
First of all, a question
for you guys.
Who likes basketball?
Quite a few people.
Anyone has heard about
Dude Perfect?
OK, for those of you that
haven't, if you like
basketball, you will
love Dude Perfect.
So to give you an idea of
what they do, I have a
little video here.
And we'll play it for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This group of Texas A&M
students have become a
national sensation
with their--
-Jaw-dropping.
-Unbelievable.
-Pretty good, right?
-It's fun to watch.
-Mind-blowing.
-Very impressive.
-amazing, incredible basketball
trick shots.
-Take a look.
-Welcome to Aggieland.
This is the world's longest
basketball shot.
-Yes!
What?
Oh my God!
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYIING]
-Yeah!
[LAUGHTER]
-Fore!
-Yarrgh.
-This is the Cowboy
Stadium shot.
-Yeah!
Ha-ha-ha!
Woo!
Cowboy Stadium!
-We found these guys
on YouTube.
-They call themselves
-Dude Perfect.
-These are our buddies
from Dude Perfect.
-Dude Perfect.
-And their videos are tearing
up the Internet.
-Burning up the Internet.
-There's talk of a video
game based on this.
-He made it!
-Those deals are all still long
shots, but, of course,
they've made those before.
-Dude Perfect.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And with
that, I would like to
introduce Coby Cotton
from Dude Perfect.
[APPLAUSE]
COBY COTTON: Thanks, Jarek,
I really appreciate it.
Guys, it's good to be here.
Like Jarek mentioned earlier,
I came from Austin, Texas.
It was 104 yesterday, and it's
going to be 106 later in the
week, so I'm pretty excited to
be in San Francisco even if
only for a short time.
As he mentioned, this has
obviously been an exciting
journey for us.
Dude Perfect's been around
for three years.
We were formed early in 2009.
These crazy guys that you saw
on the video are myself, I
have a twin brother, and
then three other
roommates in college.
So we started in our backyard,
probably like a lot of other
YouTube stories, just
goofing around.
We're all incredibly
competitive, and one of the
guys, Tyler, who's the one that
makes most of the long
shots, he was standing
behind a tree.
We'd just bought a
basketball goal.
And of course, there's
a grass backyard.
So we weren't playing your
standard pickup game.
And so he said, all right, bet
you a Jimmy John's sandwich I
can make a hook shot from
behind the tree.
And, of course, like I did every
time, I was like, dude,
I'll take that bet.
You're not going to make it.
And he drains it.
Well, then we had to get the
video camera out to record it
and show Garrett, who wasn't
there, and so we videoed Tyler
'til he made it.
And I said I can top that.
So I made one from the roof.
And one of the other guys said
let's put the goal in the back
of the truck.
So we just started making shot
after shot until we had enough
for a video and loaded
it to show to
our friends and family.
Naturally, this was during
finals week at Texas A&M. So
we were procrastinating
a little bit.
But fortunately for us, the
video started to spread.
And two mornings later, Good
Morning America woke my
brother up with a phone call and
asked if they could show
it that morning.
So everything took
off from there.
And now three years later, we've
made over 100 videos,
worked with a lot of
brands, like you
guys saw in the video.
GMC was a brand we worked with
on the airplane shot.
But we now have over 250,000
subscribers on YouTube.
We just recently crossed 80
million views, so that was
exciting for us.
Our slogan's always been "Go
Big." We just recently
launched a book with that same
title, Go Big, so that's been
really awesome as well.
Ultimately, we want to have
a Go Big approach to life.
So for us, it was really natural
to turn this whole
concept into a game.
It was one of our dreams from
the very beginning.
We were like, how cool would
it be if we had kind of an
Angry Birds-like experience
but with trick-shot
basketball.
And so a little over a year ago,
we launched our game, on
the Apple platform was the first
way that we launched
during March Madness.
And then just recently, like
Jarek mentioned, we launched
for Android during this
March Madness.
And so, here's some of the
things that you guys just saw,
some of the TV appearances.
We were listed by Advertising
Age as one of the most
in-demand brand stars on
YouTube which has been
exciting as well.
Some of the brands that we've
worked with, just
to give you a taste.
But our game, we've been
fortunate enough to be the
number one sports game on the
iPhone and on the Android
platform at different times
since the launch.
One thing that's been really,
really cool is to take the
brand that we've been able to
create on YouTube, and you
have this loyal base
of followers.
And so we didn't know if
it would work or not.
We weren't confident one way or
the other, but we figured
we would give it a try and
because these followers are so
loyal, they were really
excited to jump on
board with the game.
And so that was one reason
that it took off.
And it's been really fun to
expand that to Android now.
As you can see, we're now
approaching a million
downloads across those
platforms, and we're excited
to continue to expand it.
Today what we're excited to talk
about is a feature that
has been our number one request
since the very beginning.
We've had kids that tweet us in
and G+ us comments and talk
about how they would just love
to be able share their made
shots with their friends.
So right now, the way that it
works is if you make some
crazy shot in the game, you can
watch your replay back.
But as soon as you move on to
the next level, it's gone.
We don't have any way of saving
it, and we definitely
don't have any way of sharing
it to friends.
So that's been a huge request
from our audience.
And so when we were approached
with the opportunity to kind
of expand this with the help
of some of the people that
you've seen today and that
you're going to hear from, we
were really excited to jump on
board with that because it's
something that, like I said,
has been requested so much.
For us, one thing that would be
so incredible about this is
that, because these followers
are so engaged, they would do
a lot of the marketing for us.
So what we have is, as probably
a lot of YouTubers
can attest, you end up
with some of these
kind of super fans.
And so they'll tweet you
100 times in a day.
And so what's great about
something like this is if you
get the ability into their hands
to share their videos to
the cloud up to YouTube,
they'll
probably do it 100 times.
So, I mean, the more that we can
get people sharing videos
the better.
And I think, like Jarek
mentioned and may talk on a
little bit later, there's an
opportunity for us to monetize
those views as well.
So we're really excited
about it.
Thanks for having us
out here today.
I believe we're going to move
forward with a little bit of a
demo of how this is going
to work in our game.
Thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So Amir
has actually worked on
implementing the video capture
in Dude Perfect and
integrating with our
YouTube APIs.
And he's a Unity guru, so I'm
going to hand it over to Amir
and let you to drive this.
AMIR EBRAHIMI: So on-device
capture is a hard problem
because you have to read
back from the buffer.
You have to encode
on the device.
But we'll start first with how
it works for Dude Perfect.
So do we want to demo first or--
yeah, let's go ahead and
demo first and then
we'll go through.
Coby's going to laugh because
I am no Dude Perfect expert.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Dude Perfect.
AMIR EBRAHIMI: So I'm going to
do the hardest level, of
course, Level One.
[PLAYING VIDEO GAME]
AMIR EBRAHIMI: I was hoping I
was going to get that on the
first shot.
All right.
No pressure.
Ahhhh, man.
All right, OK, let's
do this again.
And still no.
I guess this is the better
of this or a
blue screen of death.
There we go.
[APPLAUSE]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMIR EBRAHIMI: All right.
So Dude Perfect already had a
replay theater built into the
game where you can play
back your replay.
So we'll go ahead and do that
just to watch that awesome
shot all over again.
What we did at Luminary is we
added the YouTube support.
So now I'm going to run YouTube,
and I'll explain why
we did the first shot and then
why we're going back and doing
this again.
So what we're doing now is we're
actually encoding the
video frames on the device.
We're encoding this at
15 frames a second.
And you'll notice there's
no audio, and there's
a reason for that.
The first pass that we actually
played back, we
recorded all the audio.
And this--
audio is a problem, and you'll
hear it through the other
implementations when it
comes to encoding.
So we had to record the
whole buffer of audio.
And what we do is, as we encode
the video frames, we're
giving a time slice of the
audio as well to FFmpeg.
Once this is all encoded,
we'll be able to upload
directly to YouTube.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIR EBRAHIMI: Yeah,
demo fail.
Well so, this is OAuth.
This is how--
this is something that
I was using for
debug purposes, but--
of course.
So what we have to do is--
should we just show
the video instead?
Yeah, I'll get back to that.
So in order to upload to
YouTube, you have to have
authentication, of course.
You can't just upload to this
person's account without
having authorization.
So that was a makeshift OAuth
implementation just to hook
those things up.
Those things aren't as
interesting as the encoding,
which is why that'll be replaced
with a standard UI
that you see for most apps
for authorization.
So let's go into how
all this works.
So Dude Perfect is
a Unity game.
It was written in JavaScript,
and in Unity, you can write
any other JavaScript or C#
as managed languages.
The video frames are sent off
to FFmpeg, and those are
encoded into VPA, the video part
is, and the audio frames
are encoded into Vorbis.
With that, inside of a WebM
container, you've got video
that you can send to YouTube.
And it's readily available
on YouTube.
There's not much processing
that has to happen.
So looking at the code.
So on the left, we've got the
JavaScript for the game.
They already had the
VCR capability.
And what we hooked in is, if you
look at the FFmpeg part,
we record audio on the first
pass and then record video on
the second pass.
On the C# side, where we've
written a plug-in, we yield to
the end of the frame so that we
can read back the buffer.
We then encode that
video frame.
And we're using a buffering
mechanism of rendering to one
render target, reading back
from that rendering to the
other target.
And we saw an improvement of
roughly 340 milliseconds to 41
milliseconds by doing that.
The actual encoding takes
about 200 milliseconds.
A 100 of that is for the video
encoding, and then a 100 of
that is for flipping a buffer.
So this is the interface for
the managed part of this.
These are all native functions
that come from FFmpeg or that
are written in a native DOL and
then import it into Unity.
So if we look at the actual
C code, we're
registering the codex.
We have call backs set.
FFmpeg can guess the formats for
the video and audio parts
of that if you just
hand it a file.
And then we initialize the
video and audio streams.
So for the actual video
encoding, we just use
glReadPixels.
Unity has the ability to read
back a buffer, and you can get
that pixel data in your
managed code.
But since we're using it for
FFmpeg, there's a lot of
marshaling that would go on with
copying buffers and it's
just not per-formant enough.
So instead, we read it at the
native level, and then we pass
that on to the encoding
process.
The picture comes from gl
flipped upside down, so you
have to set the buffer for the
very end, set the pitch to
negative, and then you can
flip it using SWS scale.
Additionally, with SWS scale,
you get RGBA to YUV
conversion, which you need
for VPA encoding.
And one more point that's worth
saying is that near the
bottom, there is a point where
we rescale the time frame and
set a presentation time stamp.
And it's important to know that
for the video encoding,
the audio encoding, you have
two different time bases.
One is 1 over your capture
frame rate, the audio is
usually 1 over your sample
rate for your audio.
And then you need to scale each
of your timestamps to
match that time base.
And if you end up doing this
yourself, it's important to
know that the audio and the
video don't have to use the
same time base.
So for the audio side, we're
filling up a buffer.
We encode that audio and then
set a presentation time stamp
for that as well.
And finally, the data we send to
YouTube, you can-- and this
is important too, so that the
videos get discovered.
You can set your URLs and you
can set tags for the videos
you're uploading, so that when
people search for videos, your
video will show up.
And that's all just--
if you've used YouTube's API,
you're probably already well
aware of that.
So this is an example
game play video.
But I don't know if we're
just going to--
OK.
The videos for a shot like this,
this is roughly 350K.
So it's a very quick upload once
you've already compressed
the frames on it.
And with that, I think we'll
hand it over to Danny.
[APPLAUSE]
DANNY HERMES: Where's
the clicker?
[APPLAUSE]
DANNY HERMES: Is there
no clicker?
DANNY HERMES: All right.
So I'm Danny Hermes, the other
Googler, along with Jarek.
And we worked on an approach
that's almost the opposite
extreme of this.
They did everything on the
device, and we did as little
on the device as we
possibly could.
But we still, at the end of the
day, are uploading video
to YouTube.
So before I get into the details
of how we do it, I'm
going to let Jarek demo it, and
hopefully, the demo gods
smile on us a bit more than
they did on Amir.
So let's see it.
Do we see it again?
There we go.
Wonderful.
So this game that you see
it's called Platformer.
It's a long-running open-source
game originally
for XNA Platformer on dotNet and
ported over to the PlayN
framework by us, where
we added our
hooks to make it run.
It ran on Android already, but
to do the hooks that make it
perform in the cloud.
So Jarek just jumped up on a
platform and fell and died
because he's terrible.
But hopefully, at the
end of my talk, we
can see that on YouTube.
So before I get into the
details, I just want to
provide an overview.
So first, obviously, they
start off on an
Android client right?
And then from there,
they play the game.
And the game data gets sent to
cloud storage somewhere.
So we're already
off the client.
They finished playing, and we're
already off the client.
Like I said, the
other extreme.
Then from there, once the data
gets to the cloud, it goes
through a render step.
And after it gets rendered,
the frames and sounds and
other assets get stored locally
on the machine doing
the rendering.
From there, they get encoded
into the final video that
needs to go to YouTube.
And that final video gets stored
back in the cloud.
And then, of course, after it
gets to the cloud, we upload
it to YouTube and possibly even
YouTube 3D, if that's
something that we want.
This video you see on the client
there could allow 3D.
Our proof of concept didn't
get that far.
We were more concentrating on
all these other steps, getting
into the cloud, doing the
rendering and coding rather
than the game itself.
So, what were our requirements
to actually make this work?
First, we needed Linux machines
to do our rendering.
We needed to be able to use
libraries like FFmpeg to
actually then take the rendered
code-- or excuse me,
the rendered frames and
sound assets and
turn them into video.
We needed to be able to run
arbitrary binaries, right?
In addition, we needed this
cloud storage mechanism.
We needed a place to put things
that we could go back
and grab later, and then, of
course, use to upload to
YouTube after we stored it.
And another piece, the final
piece, probably the most
important piece, was
a controller.
We needed a controller that
had as many arms as it
possibly could have to be making
sure everybody was in
the right place at the right
time, that storage was
behaving how it was supposed to,
and that storage and the
renderer were talking to each
other and all these other
parts of the process.
And, of course, we needed this
to be the most reliable piece
of the system because it's
controlling the system.
And finally, this isn't
actually a component.
It's a feature.
We needed all of these
components to be decoupled.
Because if one went down and the
others didn't, we wanted
the experience not to be
completely broken.
And we were able to
accomplish this.
So the first thing that we
satisfied was the controller.
For the controller, we used
Google App Engine, obviously
eating our own dog food.
But it's a great use for this
because we were able to set up
URL listeners.
So when the client wanted to
do something or when the
renderer wanted to do something,
it was able to make
a post to the controller
and say, hey, I'm done.
Or hey, I just started, or
do things like this.
In addition, Google App Engine
has a great uptime SLA.
So we didn't have to worry about
things like setting up
an Apache config on some machine
and worrying if that
machine would go down
or change addresses
or things like this.
We just pressed play,
and it worked.
Another feature that we use with
App Engine that was huge
for us was task queues.
You can imagine as users--
more and more users have
finished playing the game, and
they're ready to have their game
play uploaded to YouTube.
It needs to go into some
sort of queue.
So we were able to use pull task
queues with Google App
Engine to serve for
this function.
And finally, the ability to
actually send requests with
Linux machines, send data to
them and receive data from
them, was a very big, important
part of App Engine.
And then, of course, a nice
to have, maybe have the
controller send messages
back to the client.
So we use cloud-to-device
messaging within App Engine to
send messages to Android
to say hey, your
video finished uploading.
So the next piece, for cloud
storage, we used
Google cloud storage.
Since we used App Engine as our
controller, it was great
to have cloud storage because
through various libraries and
features, there's a file
system-like integration with
App Engine.
I'm not going to get into that
today, but we could treat the
cloud files as if they
were local files.
In addition, for our Linux
machines that were doing the
rendering, there was a command
line tool called GSUtil that
we could use to again pretend
like our cloud file system can
talk to the local file
system as if
they're in the same place.
So, for example, to copy our
video, our WebM video that
we've rendered and encoded, it
was as simple as calling
GSUtil CP using this library and
copying the local file--
videofile.webm--
up to this bucket GS://videos,
which represents a
bucket in the cloud.
And a bonus, after we started
working on this project,
another great piece of
decoupling, there are post
upload hooks in cloud storage.
And this is something that's
recently been announced.
And so rather than having to
have the renderer, or the
client, or some other piece tell
the controller, hey, some
upload is finished, we can just
set a hook on the actual
storage bucket, and that hook
can then send a message off to
the controller.
So this component is really
self-contained.
It's really, really
phenomenal.
And finally, again, another
super important part but maybe
not quite as specific was
our renderer machine.
So this was just a number of
Linux machines, like I said,
that we can run native
code on.
We could run our game rendering
binaries, and we
could run FFmpeg after the
fact to do other things.
And, of course, we needed
scalable resources.
So we needed to be able to have
more of these machines as
we got more users.
And of course, finally we needed
to upload the video to
cloud storage after we were done
rendering and encoding.
So how do we tie all these
pieces together?
I went through the
requirements.
I said how we satisfied them.
Now what?
So I mentioned we used PlayN,
the Platformer game, and added
in our own hooks.
So here are some of
our own hooks.
We added a class, a Java class,
called ReplayStore.
And this, among other things,
had an increment frame
function, which knew if
it was actually doing
the replay or live.
And if it was not doing the
replay, it would capture the
frame and set it to a place
where it would store it.
It is a ReplayStore.
It is what it says
it is, right?
And then using that hook in the
actual update function for
the game that's painting each
new frame as it comes, if we
knew that we were replaying,
if we have this local
replaystore object--
replaystore with a
lower case r--
if that was replaying, rather
than taking user input, we
would take the input directly
from the store and substitute
it for the user input.
And this is how our
renderer worked.
And, of course, we
would repaint the
frame and capture it.
So how did the rendering work?
We're capturing these frames and
simulating the user with
the ReplayStore.
So then what?
So the available machines of
our army of Linux machines
were able to pull for new jobs
from the controller.
I mentioned this task queue.
They just say, hey, task queue,
do you have anything
for me to do?
And if it did, then they
would start rendering.
They retrieved the game play
data, not from the controller,
but from the decoupled
component,
Google Cloud Storage.
And again, we were able to use
this awesome command line tool
GSUtil to just copy it from
the cloud bucket,
gameplay_data.jason, to
the current directory.
It's really that simple.
Just pretend like they're
on the same file system.
From there, we used our binary
to replay and capture each
individual frame that gets
painted as just a
single image file.
From there, to do the encode
step on the rendered data, we
stitched the frames together
with FFmpeg.
We also know the frame
that each individual
sound was played on.
So using SoX, or Sound eXchange,
another open source
tool, we were able to add
padding to the front of each
of the sound assets and then
squish them together to have
the rendered sound
file at the end.
And then finally, we put the
video and audio pieces
together, and we upload that
encoded video to YouTube,
first by uploading to cloud
storage and then from there
uploading to YouTube with
the controller.
OK.
So I'm pretty sure the video
is done uploading.
But before we get to that,
I want to talk about some
challenges we ran into.
And there were many, but
there were a few that
were mentioned earlier.
Amir also mentioned
this with sound.
So first, a challenging
implementation is UX intrusion.
For native games on an Android
client, you don't have to
worry about an internet
connection most the time.
And they're really fast, and
they're really great to use.
But if then you need to add the
part where you send it off
to the cloud, you don't want
to intrude and make this
experience be completely
dissonant and just kind of
terrible overall when you add
the video upload part.
Another issue, which was
actually an implementation
issue rather than a design
issue, was the inconsistent
state from what the users saw
and then from what we were
able to render.
There are various issues.
One, you have some sort of
concept of frame rate, but
each individual frame
isn't really--
whatever 60 frames per second
or whatever 30 frames per
second comes out to, you know,
17 or 34 milliseconds or all
these numbers, right?
They actually vary slightly.
And so as you go, you can
actually have things that can
end up being a little
bit out of sync.
But maybe if the game plays long
enough, there can be so
much out of sync that when you
jump on the bad guy to die,
he's no longer there, and
you don't die, right?
So these are some issues that
we're still working out and we
very much acknowledge.
And like I said,
sound is hard.
Just to give a little bit of an
example, all of our sound
assets are sampled at 44.1
kilohertz, 44,100 Hertz.
So when we were stitching with
FFmpeg, we actually had to
feed it a frame length.
And we fed it 17 milliseconds,
which comes out to about 60
frames per second.
And so 17 doesn't evenly
divide 44,100.
What does that mean?
So you have 44,100 samples.
And if you cut off some fraction
every time you need
to add a padding based on the
number of frames, then you're
actually losing fractional
samples for each
sound asset you pad.
So you actually have another
piece of inconsistent state,
and that's in the sound.
Maybe you jump, and then like
100 milliseconds, but long
enough for the human ear to
detect, you hear the guy
actually going uuuhhh to
jump, things like that.
And then finally, this
is something
which is easy to overcome.
This was specific to PlayN and
the platforms we were using.
But we're hoping to open
source this and let the
community let these problems
work themselves out.
So Jarek, Did the demo
gods smile on us?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Let's check.
DANNY HERMES: Jarek's--
OK.
[GAME PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: There we go.
DANNY HERMES: There you go.
And he's terrible.
[END GAME PLAYBACK]
DANNY HERMES: All right, with
that, I'll give the floor back
to Jarek for a short bit
so he can introduce--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Thanks Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I do
want my pointer back.
Nice try, man.
All right, so we talked about
the local approach and then
the cloud-based approach.
So now, let's talk about
something that is a little bit
in the middle.
But first I'd like to introduce
Wayne Karo from Free
Range Games.
They make wonderful mobile
games, and he will tell you
more about Free Range and
play some games as well.
WAYNE KARO: All right,
thank you very much.
OK I'd like to just start off
by doing what I do best, or
actually not really.
I'm probably one of the
worst gamers, but I do
like playing our games.
I'll explain a little bit more
about this later, but this is
the first mobile game that
our studio developed.
We've had a lot of console
experience.
That's great.
And this is a snowboarding
game.
And the object is to get as many
points as possible in a
limited amount of time.
You get points by--
[GAME PLAYBACK]
WAYNE KARO: --doing tricks.
And you can get more points
by going off the jumps.
I'm just going to go off this
one jump here and then get on
with the rest of our
presentation.
[END GAME PLAYBACK]
WAYNE KARO: OK, so that
was just a little
taste of the game.
I'm Wayne Karo, the director
of products
at Free Range games.
Our core team has been together
for well over a
decade, previously working at
Activision where we worked on
a lot of AAA console titles.
And a lot of our DNA is in
the skateboarding genre.
We worked on Tony Hawk.
And since 2009, we started our
own studio, Free Range Games,
where we're developing both
mobile and web games, trying
to bring that same console
quality to the mobile device.
And we're doing all of
the development with
the Unity 3D Engine.
Because of that, it precluded
the solution that Danny was
talking about.
And then one of the big concerns
that we had was we
were really pushing the mobile
devices to the edge of their
performance with the
snowboarding game with some of
the features that we were
trying to implement.
So we really needed a solution
that would accommodate what we
were trying to do.
Now, before I get into that
though, I'd just like to give
you a flavor of some of the
other games we're working on
because we have many things
in the pipeline.
One of the browser games that
we've just launched in open
beta up on Kongregate is
FreeFall Tournament.
This game is a space
marine shooter.
It's pretty exciting,
very intense.
And it quickly--
despite all of the early bugs
that you would see in a beta
build, it quickly rose to the
number one multiplayer game
spot there on Kongregate.
I really would appreciate any
feedback that you have.
So if you play the game, please
leave a comment in the
forums or something.
And I'm the guy that's
personally
responding to everybody.
And we're making mobile
games as well.
FreeFall Horizon is nothing
like FreeFall Tournament
except we're leveraging some
of the same art style and
trying to extend the brand
experience around this
FreeFall universe.
FreeFall Horizon is a very
familiar space theme game.
I think that if you are a fan
of quite a few of the movies
in the past, you'll recognize
some of the thematic elements.
This is an endless run game
where you go in and blow up a
reactor, and you're trying
to escape the shock wave.
And there's some interesting
mechanics where you're tilting
the device as well as missiles
and explosions.
And we hope to be launching
this quite soon.
And then of course, SummitX
Snowboarding, the very first
game that we developed.
What we're trying to do here is
leverage our experience in
the extreme sports video games
and create the most majestic
3D terrain possible as well very
realistic physics for the
character and just see what
a mobile device could do.
And then when we did something
that no other snowboarding
game has tried to do as
well is to have--
basically open up the mountain,
so you could have
lots of different paths
that you can take.
You can't completely carve
the entire mountain.
But as far as the game goes,
it does feel like that.
We were very fortunate that a
publisher out of Korea had
come to us, picked
this up, and they
launched it December 15.
And the game was featured by
Google when it was on the
Android market and very
prominently so.
So we owe a lot of thanks and
gratitude to Google for that.
And today, the game
has nearly a
million and a half downloads.
And so based off of that little
bit of success, we were
trying to think, how can we
leverage it and do something
that would be really cool
that our players
would be excited about?
So we started internally talking
about getting the game
play videos up onto YouTube.
And it just so happened the
timing was excellent.
And I was introduced to Kenji
and Jarek to kind of see if we
could do this for our
type of game.
We thought that the video would
be really great because
you'd be able to share
your awesome
moments with your friends.
And then a lot of our players
that are really into the game
are competitive.
And they want to see
not only how--
they not only want to show off
how well they're doing, but
they want to see how the other
guy has done and get some
clues on how to get higher
scores from another guy's
performance.
And then from the business side,
we're always concerned
about discovery--
getting your game--
1 in 10,000 a year--
noticed today is a
big challenge.
So if we can leverage YouTube
as a viral channel, maybe we
can get a leg up in having
our games noticed.
And then, like has been
mentioned also, monetization.
We are hoping to launch all
free-to-play games going
forward into the future.
And we want to have some way to
ensure that we can continue
maintaining the game and are
looking to a little bit of ad
support for that.
Although we've made games for
well over a decade, we've only
been making mobile games
for under a year.
And here's a few of the
things that we've
learned in that time.
That performance on the mobile
device is really critical if
you're trying to do a game that
has these high-quality 3D
graphics like ours.
Selective use of shaders and
transparencies is something
you should be well aware of.
And then bundling assets so on
lower-end devices you don't
put too high a resolution art
on to those devices to get a
performance hit.
And then if you try to do
anything new and innovative
that requires background
processing, like getting the
game play up on YouTube, you
have to be mindful of the rest
of the game design.
Because we're doing all of the
design on desktops but the
game runs on a mobile device,
we just found that the best
way that we can ensure that
we're having acceptable
performance for the player is
just to continuously build and
then test, build and
test on the device.
And then the mobile system,
it's not like designing a
console game.
There's so many different
devices out there.
We really had to work pretty
hard to build a flexible UI
system into Unity so that we
could handle all the different
screen dimensions for this
heterogeneous device mix.
But the thing, above all, that
I'm really excited about in
this space is that hardware is
continuing to advance very,
very rapidly, opening new
possibilities for innovation,
such as what we've
done today--
getting the game play
up on YouTube.
And as a business strategy,
we're trying to leverage these
technological advances so that
people can find our games, get
excited about them, because
they're going to be giving new
play styles and other new
experiences to the consumer.
All right, and I'll return
it to Jarek, thank you.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Now, I would
like to introduce Jens--
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --Owen from
SeeMeGaming to talk about
their cloud-based rendering
solution.
JENS OWEN: Thank you, Jarek.
So we're 3D driver guys, and we
come at this from a little
bit different perspective.
We've done high-end
workstation tuning for drivers--
3D drivers--
low cost laptops, desktops,
and we've gone into the
low-power phones and
tablets space.
And we've applied this to our
SeeMeGaming technology to take
a different approach to
game play capture.
What we do is we intercept the
3D command stream before it
gets sent down to the
graphics subsystem.
The advantage of taking this
approach, you don't need a
replay capability in your game,
and it's much faster
than waiting until it's rendered
and reading back
those pixels.
The other benefit to SeeMeGAMING
is we've added an
in-game integration for sharing
with YouTube and your
other social networks.
So the dialogue you see here,
this screen, is something that
you can integrate
in your game.
It's under your game's
control.
And finally, as Jarek mentioned,
we're a hybrid
approach, so we can offload the
video conversion to the
cloud, which saves time and
battery on your device.
So in the demo that you saw
Wayne run earlier, we are
actually capturing the entire
run, the entire level.
And Amir instrumented that game
so that it would mark the
best jump and capture
the previous 10
seconds of that jump.
At the end of that run, we were
sharing and basically
popping up that dialogue.
You didn't see it after
Wayne's run there.
We worked with Unity and Amir
from Luminary Productions to
enable the capture of that
command stream as it's emitted
from the Unity engine.
And then finally, after all of
this is done and captured in
the 3D command stream again,
we're uploading that command
stream up into the cloud.
It's being converted there to
video, and that saves time and
battery on the device.
Amir provided us with these
code samples here.
On your left, you see that with
a simple inclusion of a
header file, we're able to
redirect that command stream
by recompiling that engine
and send that out
to our capture system.
On the right here, a couple of
code changes that were made
just to basically-- whenever
you're creating an open field
context, say let's
start capturing
this 3D command stream.
And when you're done, let's
clean it up and stop.
At the application level, there
was a couple changes
that were made to
SummitX itself.
Again, I mentioned that we
marked the best jump.
So actually for every
jump, we do an SMG
marked recording call.
Then we give it the number
of seconds you need to go
backwards in time, and
that's the part
that's marked for sharing.
And then the actual share
menu itself at
the end of the level.
And along with that call to SMG
Share Recording, we can
put a string in there that
references back to your
application, getting the viral
effect, the marketing effect
you want to see with the
YouTube channel.
The big difference we see in
this approach of capturing the
command stream versus reading
back pixels is really in the
sheer size of the number
of pixels.
We have 3 gigabytes worth of
pixel data to read back versus
in a very complex game like the
snowboarding game maybe
100, 200 megabytes of data
for the entire level.
For simpler games, we looked at
Dude Perfect, for example,
cool graphics, but their stream
was a lot smaller.
The whole 10 shots is about
a 30-megabyte file.
So it's just a lot smaller.
It's orders of magnitude
smaller than
reading back the pixels.
So that's the advantage of
reading the 3D command stream.
And at this point, we have a
game play video that we can
show you from the creation
of that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This
is a video of--
was it Wayne playing?
So this one that we
created earlier.
This is what it looks like.
[GAME PLAYBACK]
[END GAME PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right, and
then we did get the Dude
Perfect video uploaded.
I think Wi-Fi is a little
slow, but let's see, 26
minutes ago.
There's Amir's awesome shot.
[GAME PLAYBACK]
[END GAME PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Thank you.
Let's just switch back.
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So at this
point, I'd like to summarize.
If you have nice games, if you
throw in a little YouTube API
integration, you'll make
your gamers happy.
And we have a few minutes
left open for questions.
I think our SummitX video
is still rendering.
It might finish by the time
we're done talking.
If not, Amir is going to
post it on his stream.
Any questions for any
of the speakers?
There's a question.
Maybe you could use the
mic if possible.
[AUDIENCE]
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, so the
question is about the audio
processing.
You want to take that, Amir?
AMIR EBRAHIMI: Cool, thanks.
So the audio on that one, just
using a fixed-size queue
essentially for the 15 seconds
audio that we want.
I mean, we're capturing
real time using a
DSP filter and Unity.
You can capture all the audio
that comes through.
So we just capture the
last 15 seconds.
And when we mark a point, we
send that buffer off as a copy
and we keep recording the audio
in case there's a new
mark point.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Any
other questions?
Going once, going twice.
If not, then thank you very
much for coming to the
session, and please get in
touch with us if you are
planning on the integration
of your mobile game into--
integration of YouTube API
into your mobile game.
Have
fun at I/O. [APPLAUSE]